à ce dossier on va revenir sur ce fameux
voyage à Tahiti Dani dalgo la mère de
Paris pour rappel l'objectif de ce
voyage qui se voulait officiel était de
visiter les installations olympiques du
site d'une épreuve de surf bon ça
c'était selon la mérie de Paris on s'est
vite rendu compte qu'elle avait un petit
coup de Moen qu'elle voulait aller se
dorer la pilule à la
Tahiti et elle en a profiter pour passer
de semaines chez sa fille en fait qui
vit là-bas oui bah forcémentah quand tu
as de la famille bah forcément forcément
tu as une épreuve de sur tu as la
famille bah forcément tu tu couples les
deux bah c'est normal c'est normal alors
ce
déplacement pour certaines personnes ne
paraît pas forcément comme très
professionnel et a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre est-ce que pour vous qui pense
que c'est un déplacement
professionnel
merci qui pense que c'est un déplacement
professionnel donc la base oui mais donc
non les mecs dites la vérité qui pense
que c'est un déplacement professionnel
Gill Verdes non mais Gill non mais sans
mais mais mais tu vas te de la
gueule du monde encore combien de temps
non mais sans rigoler mais mais tu dis
quoi mais tu as quoi tu as quel intérêt
alors parce que tu dois avoir un intérêt
forment est-ce que tu habites à Paris
non j'en ai aucun tu habites à Paris tu
habites à Paris j'en ai aucun Mo j'ite à
Paris tu habites à Paris habite à Paris
c'est parce que la plainte elle est
déposée par la droite et exaement bravo
c'est idéologiquement par principe il
peut pas être du côté de la droite donc
il va être forcément du côté même de M C
il est du côté de ceux qui croi qu'elle
est partie pour un voyage professionnel
je peux
poserer question g puisque c'est un
voyage professionnel tu peux nous dire
un peu quelles sont les compétences en
surf de
[Applaudissements]
Madame petit rap et on a David al
conseiller de Paris qui qui est le qui
je peux dire excellent et il va il va
nous expliquer l'affaire parce qu'ils
ont porté plainte ça va chier des
bularies
regardez
il y a quelques jours les Français ont
découvert qu'anidalgo avait effectué un
voyage de 3 semaines à Tahiti pour
inspecter les futures infrastructures
pour les preuv de surf à quelques mois
des Jeux Olympiques c'est un voyage qui
a coûté près de 60000 € mais ce voyage
où la mère de Paris en a profité pour
rendre visite à sa fille a immédiatement
fait polémique vos notes de frais opaqu
dont on sait maintenant qu'elle finance
votre garde-robe et les voyage
injustifié et aujourd'hui l'association
AC antiorruption s'interroge pour savoir
qui a financé ce déplacement et déclare
avoir porté plein de contrix pour
détournement de fond public soit le
voyage était officiel et donc devait
être pris en charge par la ville soit il
était privé et devait l'être à titre
personnel non mais c'est un malade
excusez-moi je parlais J il est
incroyable il est incroyable David
alpant conseiller de Paris est avec nous
merci euh d'être là je voulais qu'
revoir cette image qui a énormément
buzzé il y a quelques jours lors d'un
dans d'un échange vous aviez avec
annieidalgo elle avait confondu Midas de
la mythologie grecque dont vous faisz
référence avec la célèbre marque
d'entretien de voiture je vous j que
c'est vrai bon bah là c'est comme çaad
Volter non mais c'est incroyable ça pour
moi c'est une des images de l'année non
mais sans rigoler non mais c'est
extraordinaire regardez regardez le roi
mida chers collègues il transformait
tout ce qu'il touchait en or et bien
vous madame Hidalgo vous êtes l'exact
contraire vous êtes l'antimidas tout ce
que vous touchez y compris l'URE des
Parisiens ce bijisou qui est notre
capitale vous le transformez en plomb je
n'ai plus de voiture donc je ne sais pas
du tout à quelle référence de Midas vous
vous faites ici ça doit être culturel ça
doit être
culturelidalgo tu lui disidalo tu dis tu
as écouté le dernier album de Renault
elle dit qui la
zafrade elle elle est elle est focus he
c'est c'est un non mais ça c'est
extraordinaire vous aviez compris
qu'elle avait pas compris je je je me
pose toujours la question en fait en
revoyant cette séquence pour laquelle
d'ailleurs on est on est nommé avec ma
partenaire pour le prix de l'humour
politique 2023 bravo c'est bien bien
j'espère qu'elle sera rentrée de Tahiti
si on le reçoit mais mais je me posais
la question parce que là elle a fait une
pub d'enfer à Midas mais là avec cette
affaire de Tahiti je me demande si elle
fait pas pour Tahiti Douche peut-être
qu'elle est en train de se reconvertir à
faire du placement de
produits c'était une
influ on comprendrait pourquoi sup plus
de Paris non mais c'est ça je crois que
elle est chez Speedy là alors on
par regardez regardez on mettait la
voilà céta pour inter TER
Flora dis là c'est mais c'est vrai c'est
c'est un truc de fou c'est c'est
extraordinaire bon qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce voyage à Tahiti bah c'est
une affaire absolument
invraisemblable c'est c'est le compte
des m et une nuit tous les soirs on a eu
une petite histoire supplémentaire et
nouvelle alors un coup elle devait aller
faire du surf ou visiter le site de surf
olympique à tupo à Tahiti puis alors le
lendemain ah ben non je suis pas allé
ouais ah ben en fait si on y est allé
non c'est pas moi c'est mon adjoint mais
pas le bonjour bon et puis après elle
nous explique ah oui mais j'ai été
mandaté par le ministre de l'Intérieur
pour faire mon déplacement et hier
Gérald d'andin démment catégoriquement
il a jamais été l'émissè du
catégoriquement énorme my mais j'adore
parce que comment comment comment quand
à ce niveau-là tu peux faire des mythos
comme ça c'est Gérardin qui m'a dit
violer Gérard darin moment il il il la
presse il est au courant de tout il va
dire moment non mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces conneries non mais tu vois ou
pas non mais c'est incroyable non mais
c'est fou alors qu'est-ce qu'elle risque
là parce que vous avez déposé la vous
avez déposé plainte alors nous on a
enquêté on a posé des questions j'ai
posé des questions très précises à
Madame hiidalgo j'en ai posé SEP je n'ai
eu aucune réponse naturellement ça n'est
pas la droite parisienne qui dépose
plainte c'est une association non non
mais qu'on soit très clair c'est une
association qui s'appelle qui qui lutte
contre la corruption d'accord qui
s'appelle AC et
qui
absolumentèou et et qui au regard des
des éléments considère qu'il pourrait y
avoir constitution d'une infraction
pénale parce que l'affaire est très
grave après la Parisienne va être
contente aussi deouiah oui c'est pas qu'
tout le monde est content on est content
on est scandalisé mais malgré droite pas
droite on est tout content nous on n'est
pas content de voir l'argent Paris il
est comme ça parce que on parle de
l'argent qui provient des impôts payés
par les
Parisiens pas une commission de
déontologie qui qui a vérifié qui a dit
que c'était dans les règ bidon moi JEI
je faire une enquête
de tous nom par Idalgo donc forcément te
dire comme si avait une enquête on tombe
dessus non oui et puis en plus
curieusement elle a saisi la
commissionontologie qui normalement doit
is àour quanda est c'est domage il
aurait mie qu' la question avant partir
àah pour savoir si ça correspondait bien
à une vie mission vous pensez que ça va
être compliqué pour penser qu'elle est
caramélisé ou
pas qu'elle est déjà depuis un certain
temps mais elle s'en sort à chaque fois
c'est à chaque fois elle est voilà réélu
enfin les Parisiens la détestent tous
les parisiens déteste il a pas un
chauffeur de taxi
dire
maisis alors comment t'exlique toi toi
le roi
al attends attends attends parce que lui
c'est quand même lui c'est le roi des
donneurs de leçon donc on va voir on va
voir ce que va dire le donneur de leçon
sur ce voyage à Tahiti tu sais lui c'est
quand même parce qu'on a la chance
d'avoir dans cette émission voilà tout
le monde ne l'a pas tout le monde ne l'a
pas lui on a quand même la chance
d'avoir le donneur de leçon en chef du
PAF donc non mais c'est vrai tout le
monde ne l'a pas on a la chance qu'il
soit chez nous donc heureusement et ben
quand on a quand on a une pépite pareil
et ben les gars on on le laisse
s'exprimer non mais c'est vrai on a la
pépite on a la pépite du P dire la pique